I love my beautiful family
love my kids love my wife Corey Hardrick
has nothing but love for his estranged
wife Tia Mowry
I'm doing fantastic yeah
yeah I'm doing great I feel very blessed
the actor opened up on Instagram live
just days after it was revealed that the
two are calling it quits after 14 years
of marriage
it's love y'all I love y'all I love
y'all for real
okay I love my beautiful family
love my kids love my wife I love all you
guys just know that it's all love okay
Tia first shared the news of their
divorce on Instagram earlier this month
posting this pick and writing in part
quote these decisions are never easy and
not without sadness adding that they
will maintain a friendship as they
co-parent the two children they share
eleven-year-old son cree and
four-year-old daughter Cairo family is
so important to me quote I am grateful
for all the happy times we had together
and want to thank my friends family and
fans for your love and support as we
start this new chapter moving forward in
our lives
ET was with the sister sister star
earlier this week where she echoed all
that thanking fans for all the love
there's been a lot of fans who have
really just showed so much love and
support what do you make of that
I am really I have to be honest with you
so overwhelmed by all of the support and
the love that I have received over the
past week or two
um and I'm just so grateful of the
community and just the fans that I have
and the women you know you guys really
do ride for our girls and I really
really appreciate that you know I'm all
about inspiring and encouraging
um and I mean the DMS that I have gotten
from so many women that are going
through the same thing and just saying
how they admire my courage and my
strength it I mean it has just been
I feel so blessed Tia's twin sister
Tamara also praised Tia's strength
during a recent stop by today with Hoda
and Jenna she is strong but I know right
now she just kind of just wants to
you know just kind of just process it
all take it all in and you know be a
little private about that and you know
as a sister you know I'm just gonna
respect that news of Tia split came on
the same day Tamara released her Memoir
and when ET spoke to Tia just days
before announcing her split she teased
that she has some stories to tell of her
own is it your turn to put out a memoir
who you know what I was thinking about
this I think in the next few years maybe
like you have a lot of stories I do
I do I'm a little mysterious I feel like
I do have a lot to say it's just when am
I gonna say it
of course the former couple met in the
early 2000s tied the knot in 2008 then
welcomed their son in 2011 and their
daughter in 2018. she's only four years
old but I'm a strong believer that
children learn through observation and
so she motivates me to make the right
decisions no matter what those decisions
are whether they're in relationships
whether they're with your job your
career she really does she's an
extension of who I am so what's next for
Tia here's what she told E.T what does
this next chapter of life look like for
you authenticity I think authenticity it
it's very magical when you are living in
your truth and your honesty I feel like
amazing wonderful things happen and so I
just want to encourage you know all the
women out there to live in their truth
and to live in their authenticity and we
got you you know what I mean we're all
in this together it's about a community
and supporting each other and
encouraging each other and inspiring
each other and I mean there's so many
great things that are happening in my
life and I just feel so grateful
um and blessed
[Music]
thank you